[Musica]
[Applauso]
grazie Allora avete capito la situazione
è grave
se non è grave e occorre la filosofia
non perché la filosofia risolva le cose
questo non è mai successo in tutta la
storia dell'umanità la Sofia e non
risolve nessun problema sono migliaia di
anni che l'avevo Sofia si sta occupando
di come porre i problemi quindi è un
problema da affrontare prima fai
filosofia
L'unica cosa a cui serve la filosofia
poi intervengono quelli che risolvono i
tecnici gli economisti gli statisti e
gli ingegneri quelli risolvono però
prima per chiederti qualche cosa c'è che
non Ma allora si chiama il filosofo
Io lo so posso essere utile in questo
campo perché mi interesso di filosofia
della mente da un po' di tempo magari
chissà può tornare utile la situazione è
grave è grave è soltanto della filosofo
della vegetazione grave è grave È
urgente
e vasta e nuova peggio di così
quindi che cosa serve dal punto di vista
della filosofia della mente la genialità
la genialità non da parte degli esperti
questa parola qui il countdown e degli
anni 40 fine anni 40 quando c'era la
guerra fredda durante la guerra fredda
c'era il problema adesso scoppia la
bomba non scoppia la bomba era terribile
a quel tempo è una situazione di ansia
costante costante costante e c'era
l'idea del countdown è cominciato il
conto alla rovescia lui c'era un
orologio una rivista americana che
segnava meno 5 a
23:50 a mezzanotte ogni settimana
spostava la differenza tra adesso è
mezzanotte perché mezzanotte la Copiamo
la bomba ad è quello lì era un countdown
per riguardare solamente gli statisti
capi di Stato Krusciov Kennedy e così
via degli anni 50-60 è attualmente il
countdown che è in corso e democratico
cioè voi potete intervenire voi potete
intervenire come ecco con i bisogni e
con le opinioni non mi va voglio questo
non voglio quest'altro la gente vuole
questo la gente vuole quest'altro poi
poter intervenire quindi genialità
adesso non come gli anni 40 genialità
devono essere dei geni Krusciov e
Kennedy no dovete essere voi Voi
difficile come si fa a essere dei geni
ci vorrà una biografia importante si può
aiutare una biografia in cui sei Orfano
disperato oppure meditatore oppure hai
avuto l'illuminazione può aiutare ma non
è non è decisiva
diventare persone geniali è una cosa che
richiede poco come vedrete e i mezzi li
avete tutti per quello che riguarda la
filosofia della mente Bisogna soltanto
appoggiarsi nella mente alle parti
giuste
attualmente sei una persona vi parla di
sostenibilità cioè di crisi ambientale
di pericolo imminente dice ci vuole
razionalità
sentimento
e paura Ecco errore
la ragione
che consiste nel saper spiegare degli
schemi già presi già sviluppati e già
che ci sono stati risultati validi nella
ragione ha ragione infatti come la
matematica impara il primario operazioni
quello lì è razionalità tutti gli
animali ce l'hanno noi la usiamo quando
parcheggiamo quando parliamo col
commercialista quando corteggiamo
qualcuno sotto i sistemi razionali
stazione già nota la situazione attuale
non è nota non è nota invece della
razionalità occorre il pensiero
Come pensiero ragionare come pensare No
a ragionare non è come pesare sono due
nemici nella nostra mente ragione e
pensiero La ragione si impiega schemi
già noti pensiero invece non impiega
schemi noti
pensiero fa una domanda si fa una
domanda che la ragione non fa mai
tu parcheggi e parcheggi con la ragione
tu corteggi e corteggi con la ragione tu
parli col commercialista e parli col
commercialista con la ragione non ti
chiedi mai la domanda del pensiero che
perché
pensiero è bravissimo sul perché
e perché per il pensiero è un lancio
verso l'indescrivibile che si era una
cosa non si può descrivere e funziona
sempre è facile Semplice è come il
tennis Tu tiri una pallina
e ti arriva la pallina non sai da dove
viene la tua domanda perché
qual è la soluzione nel punto di vista
più originale dell'orizzonte è questo il
pensiero pensiero tutti quanti ce
l'abbiamo se spegne la ragione gli
schemi che conosci già viene fuori il
pensiero non devi impararlo Non occorre
leggere perché è leggero leggero
semplicemente ciò il coraggio Quando
tiri la pallina verso questo mistero
questo universo intero ti arriva appena
domanda col pensiero dopo pochi secondi
10 quindi il secondo e ti arriva la
risposta non sai da dove non sai come
devi solo prenderla Se non la prendi se
la prende qualcun altro poi ricevuto una
buona idea detto Non puoi dire No guardi
la mia
perché nessuno deve dimostrare devi solo
prenderla tu e si può pensiero bambini
ce l'hanno No perché perché perché
perché perché
poi sentimento no sentimento Lascialo
perdere Adesso retoriche del sentimento
Assolutamente sì non conta niente
il sentimento è una parola lati di
Latina che finisce con mento
sensazione che lo poso il sentimento è
una parola di origine latina che finisce
con azione le parole di origine latina
che finiscono con mento indicano una
Tione per esempio convincimento convinci
qualcuno innamoramento decidi di
innamorarti
le parole che finiscono con zione sono
passive
per esempio infatuazione non la scegli
non fa niente ti capita e basta ma che
impressione che Una contrazione la
sensazione è passiva Non ti richiede
nessuno sforzo sentimento cosa fai nella
tua psiche sentimento frena
limita le sensazioni sentimento serve a
mantenere le situazioni già esistenti
per esempio tu ami una persona
sentimento No figuriamoci se è uno di
queste cose qui non mi risulta me quello
che dici tu cioè sentimento tutti
parlano bene
Gianni Morandi Vasco Rossi
Manzoni Sì sì quello che dico io Non è
non è nei testi ancora non sono cose da
tante nuove il sentimento Cosa fa tu ami
una persona cosa fai Fai una censura su
tutte le sensazioni che hai elimini
tutte quelle che potrebbero farti
interessare ad altre persona oppure a
farti accorgere che la persona che ami a
meno qualità di quelle che tu pensavi
non dite a casa queste cose poi che vi
dico che se mi ha detto che adesso io ti
amavo però poi ho sentito tu di' che
l'hai pensato tu
sennò poi mi scrive
sentimento sentimento e ragione per
d'accordissimo tra di loro sono alleati
stretti quando lo statista non sa come
farti pagare le tasse non s'ha da
commenti razionali e farti fare la
tessera ricorre all'amore di Patria
appartenenti al gruppo il senso del
dovere è un sentimento senso di colpa è
un sentimento tutte cose che ti tengono
all'interno di una situazione Giannotta
la sensazione invece eccezionale non
richiede nessuno sforzo tu guardi e dici
mi piace non mi piace mi insospettisce
non mi insospettisce rifare le sue forze
guardo Lì come va quello lì mi va Ecco
guardo lì e dico questo non lo capisco
il pensiero dici dici a me e cioè
sensazione pensiero vanno molto
d'accordo come Ragione e sentimento
censimento lasciarli da parte niente
rettorica in questo periodo sensazione e
pensiero la sensazione è un'altra
caratteristica interessantissima Le
sensazioni sono più grandi
Le sensazioni sono più grandi del tuo
linguaggio
Cioè tu quella sensazione
sai di più di quello che puoi dire
esempio di cosa sa una pesca
tu sai di cosa sia una pesca lo sai
perfettamente di questa una pesca tu
sensazione ma non puoi dirlo
pensa le sensazioni che mondo ti
allargano e quantità di dati ti metto a
disposizione che non puoi dire che non
puoi dire cose senza risultato un gatto
che non parla
conosci un mondo più grande del tuo
un bambino che non sa ancora parlare
Se tu metti da parte Ragione e
sentimento che sono quelle due abilità
di cui parlano tutti quanti quasi tutti
Non oggi però quasi tutti quanti quelli
che ti cercano di attirare l'attenzione
sulla ambientalismo e sulla
sostenibilità ti prendi razionalità e
sentimento lasciali da parte pensa
sensazione
tuo scopo diciamo essere geniale Allora
allargare di colpa se tu senti le tue
sensazioni e metti in moto il pensiero
ci vede come si fa tu hai un mondo
vastissimo e diventi più geniale
litigio geniale su essere più generi
geniale saggio è pericoloso per le
autorità
perché è geniale perché è la Bori se usi
le stazioni un numero di dati
enormemente superiore a una persona che
usa la ragione
elabori questi dati è più saggio Perché
Perché nella sensazione tu senti che
questo è un parere questo è un altro
parere sono contrapposti Ma tu li
capisci tutti e due con la stazione
la ragione non puoi la ragione ti
schieri da una parte o dall'altra o
sentimento ti Scary una sensazione no
col pensiero di capisci tutti e due
quindi la menta e larga pericoloso per
l'autorità perché perché nessuna
autorità religiosa statale sopporterebbe
di avere un popolo di geni un popolo di
Leonardi un popolo di Raffaelli o quello
di Michelangeli e sono non li puoi più
fregare quelli lì
E se tu ti accorgi di essere geniale
comincio ad avere dei bisogni da persona
geniale Se hai bisogno di persona
geniale a certo punto non ti va non è
che non ti vanno per motivi razionali di
oggi no Non li sopporto queste cose che
mi dicono non sopporto Queste cose
succedono e se siamo in tanti a essere
geniali che è semplice vi dico diventa
un opinione pubblica pericolosissima Per
tutti quelli che vogliono gestire adesso
un certo disfacimento del mondo diceva
ho paura se è una cosa che va contro lo
stato si vince la paura la paura è
un'emozione le emozioni sono molto utili
emozioni si è scoperto da poco anche
questa cosa quello che ho detto fino
adesso non si è ancora scoperto quello
che vi dico adesso ho scoperto da poco
con €1 si cologia che le emozioni di cui
la psicologia parla pochissimo Sono
invece molto utili al cervello perché
l'emozione non tanti otto nove sono
emozioni dei canali di ormoni che
arrivano al cervello lo fa diventare più
intelligente esempio di emozioni la
collera
se la collera arriva il cervello non
diventa più intelligente
e il desiderio sessuale sul desiderio
sessuale lascia arrivare al cervello
diventa più intelligente al cervello il
gioco
il prendersi cura grande scoperta della
neuropsicologia di questi ultimi anni se
tu ti prendi cura di una pianta sei più
intelligente di uno che non ha una
pianta
se ti prendi cura di una pianta è di un
animale domestico sei più intelligente
di uno che abita da solo
e così via questi sono emozioni poi c'è
l'emozione cosiddetta paura
dei mostri La paura non è un'emozione
primaria la paura è una degradazione di
altre emozioni
importante segnatevelo cercate di
ricordarmelo anche se tu la fine di una
giornata così intensa emozione come un
fiume ogni emozione con un fiume collere
desideri 116 mi viene interrotto cosa
succede esonda
esonda Non arriva più lui deve arrivare
e alla Ge territori circostanti
Ecco la paura e quando una qualsiasi
altra emozione
desiderio gioco prendersi cura viene
bloccata
quell'emozione Si si frena esonda una
sensazione di paura per esempio io provo
desiderio per una certa persona voglio a
cagare conversazione questa persona
freno per motivi di qualsiasi tipo
perché decido io per educazione da quel
momento in avanti e diventò timido non
sono timido perché freno divento Timido
perché ho frenato
capite
poi segnatevelo poi l'ho capito dopo
prima pochi minuti per cui
segnatevelo che poi tra poco lo capite
ci ripensa te mi sembra di aver pensato
voi per cui sembrava una cosa voglio più
intelligente se vedi che serve dico io
ecco quindi se tu hai paura di una
qualsiasi cosa non è normale
eh Perché c'è una tua emozione che viene
frenata non stai facendo qualcosa che ti
piacerebbe fare
Quindi hai paura di essere geniale Fermi
tutti cosa non stai facendo Che ti
piacerebbe
funziona Io sto preso da poco da 20
scoperto 40 anni fa a quest'ora altro
che ho scoperto da poco e cambiamento è
stato eccezionale quindi ho paura Fermi
tutti cosa non faccio che mi
entusiasmerebbe
lo scopri E ricorda una paura pazza non
il coraggio No la corda ti di quello che
tu senti a questo punto tu hai le
istruzioni se te le ricordi sicuramente
dei ricordi se se te le ricordi hai
queste istruzioni per essere così
semplicemente
geniale cioè aperto a tantissimi stimoli
esterni è Pronto a cogliere idee nuove e
a far sentire i tuoi bisogni diversi e
non hai più nessuna scusa
per non esserlo
Mi raccomando quindi noi ci no potevo
essere geniale Ma no Non lo so tra
cent'anni diranno che bello quel periodo
storico in cui sono accorti di poter
essere geniali e quando scopriranno che
tu eri nato in quel periodo è tu eri
geniale Purtroppo
non ho sentito quel intervento di Ted
per cui
[Musica]
Ecco non fate quella figura lì Mi
raccomando Grazie per l'attenzione
Grazie
[Applauso]